hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American superhero action
film called Ant-Man and the WASP
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
hot wing 3D here we come almost there
the movie kicks off with the renowned
physicist Hank Pym and his wife Janet
several years ago while working for
shield he discovered the magical
particles through which one could shrink
in size or become excessively large Hank
and his wife made suits for themselves
using these particles and fought against
the bad guys in 1987 during one of their
missions they had to stop a Soviet
nuclear missile from detonating they
landed on the missile and shrinked it
into the size of insects but even that
was not enough to gain entry inside of
it so with time running out Janet
decided to risk her life she reduced
herself even further until she reached
subatomic size then she successfully
entered the missile and destroyed it
from within hence saving the country
from catastrophe however in the process
Janet got stuck in the quantum realm a
dimension which consists of nothing but
endless void she tried her best to
regain her original size and get back to
the original world but failed as a
result Hank Williams believed that she
passed away and he moved on with his
life however several years later when
the Ant-Man Scott Lang manages to get
out of the quantum realm Hank gets
renewed hope that his wife is still
alive and that there is a way to get her
back if she's still in there she's gonna
be pissed his daughter hope is also
ready to help him in any way possible
meanwhile after the events of Captain
America's Civil War The Avengers
including Scott are under house arrest
because they violated the sokovia
Accords in Leipzig Scott spends most of
his day playing with his daughter Cassie
with the help of his best friend Lewis
he has set up a mini playground
throughout the house however one day
when he accidentally breaks the fence
with his feet the FBI arrives to check
on him detective Wu warns him to stay
out of trouble saying he only has three
days of house arrest left after that he
is free to go wherever he wants
Overjoyed by the Revelation Scott tries
his best to pass the time he plays the
drums practices magic and does all sorts
of stuff which he never imagined he'd do
but one day when he gets into the tub to
take a bath he suddenly starts dreaming
of playing hide and seek with Janet and
a young hope startled he wakes up and
immediately calls Hank it is revealed
that the two have not been in contact
since his house arrest Scott tells him
that he had a strange Vision about Janet
and conveniently forgets to mention it
happened while he was in the bath but
Hank thinks he's joking and ends the
call a few moments later Scott notices
something flying around the house but
before he can investigate it sedates him
causing him to pass out when he wakes up
he finds himself being driven somewhere
by hope it turns out she was the insect
that was flying around his house earlier
she wants him to meet her dad and help
him get Janet back Scott agrees but just
then he realizes that he is on house
arrest he yells at Hope for taking him
away when he was only one day away from
being released however she calms him
down and explains that she took off his
ankle bracelet and put it on a giant ant
she found in the apartment now the FBI
will have no clue that he is out of the
house in the next scene they arrive at
the lab where Hank seems to have created
a tunnel to the quantum realm Scott
takes a brief look at it and then starts
explaining about his dream and detail
hearing this Hank and hope are stunned
because Janet loved to play hide and
seek they deduced that Scott has somehow
connected to her after spending some
time in the quantum realm this might
also mean that Janet is trying to
communicate through him possibly to give
away her exact coordinates meanwhile
Hank reveals that although the tunnel is
almost ready they are missing a key
Electronic Component so they are going
to meet someone who can provide it for
them before they leave Hank shrinks the
lab to the size of a briefcase and takes
it with him surprisingly a transparent
figure is eavesdropping on them from
nearby the three arrive at Sada
restaurant but only hope gets in while
the guys stay inside the van and monitor
the situation hope meets a black market
dealer named Sonny Birch and asks if he
has the component she is looking for the
latter says yes but he wants a
substantially large sum for it when hope
tries to negotiate Birch refuses saying
he has other clients can give them a
better deal upset hope pretends to leave
but the very next second she changes
into her wasp suit and starts fighting
with Birch's goons she has blasters and
other high-tech gadgets on her suit with
the help of which she easily defeats
them hope then approaches Birch and
snatches the component from him but as
she's walking away the transparent
figure from earlier attacks her it is
able to pass through any solid which
makes Hope's attacks useless when the
situation gets out of hand Ant-Man also
joins in on the fight however even with
all of his expertise the transparent
figure manages to get away with the
components to make matters worse it also
gets inside Hank's van and steals his
briefcase the old man is furious and
devastated as the lab was his only hope
of getting Janet back after a while
Scott brings the father-daughter Duo to
his friend Lewis's office because he
believes that home is not safe anymore
the three then start thinking of ideas
to get the briefcase back Scott asks
sank if he knows someone who can help
them in this situation and the latter
brings up his former friend Bill Foster
it is revealed that they were very close
in the past but because of an incident
they stopped talking nonetheless Hank
decides to pay him a visit and ask for
help elsewhere the transparent entity
takes off its mask and reveals itself to
be a girl her name is Ava Starr she
keeps on phasing in and out and by the
look on her face it is evident that she
is in a lot of pain Ava then steps
inside a special chamber to control her
powers and recharge meanwhile Scott and
the Gang arrive at the University where
bell Works he is teaching his students
but as soon as he sees Hank he sends
everyone away the two are still bitter
over their past and almost get into a
fight but right then Scott spots
detective Wu outside and stresses that
they have to leave before going though
Bill explains that they can locate the
lab by modifying one of The suit's
Regulators Hank mentions that they can't
use the new Ant-Man suit because it is
still in its trial phase so Scott
proposes that they use the old one the
only problem is that he gave it to his
daughter and she has taken it to school
in a trophy case later Scott and hope
sneak into Cassie's school disguised as
insects everything goes according to
plan for a while but then Scott's suit
malfunctions forcing him to hide inside
a room as he tries to fix his suit he
grows to the size of a child Ant-Man
more like this scene made me my
pants man fortunately before anyone can
spot them they get to Cassie's classroom
and retrieve the old suit out of her
trophy case using the method Bill
described the trio then locates Ava's
home and finds the lab they see her
resting inside the chamber and try to
sneak out without waking her up but fail
Ava quickly knocks them out and ties
them to separate chairs in a shocking
turn of events it is revealed that her
Mentor is none other than Bill he
adopted Ava after her parents tragically
passed away when she was a child
following this the movie goes into a
flashback several years ago when Hank
was working for shield he had an
assistant named Elias he was very good
at his work but when Hank found out that
he sold their ideas into the black
market he immediately fired him however
this didn't stop Elias from conducting
experiments his main goal was to reach
the quantum realm and for that he made a
tunnel unfortunately one day in the
midst of an experiment the tunnel became
unstable his wife tried to escape with
their young daughter who is revealed to
be none other than Ava however the
little girl ran back for her father soon
the tunnel exploded killing her parents
and leaving her with destabilized
molecules resulting in her uncontrolled
phasing now Ava along with Bill wants to
use Janet's Quantum energy to treat her
disease and bring her back to normalcy
she knows that the procedure may result
in her death but it is a risk she is
willing to take as Hank listens to all
this he suddenly holds his chest and
fakes having a heart attack he orders
Bill to quickly retrieve his meds from a
small box and when the latter obliges a
swarm of trained ants are Unleashed they
grow to a large size and free the trio
allowing them to escape with the lab in
the next scene they arrive at a forest
and enlarge the lab Hank tries his best
to work the device but has trouble doing
so just then Scott starts acting like
Janet and enters some coordinates on the
computer it turns out she has once again
started communicating through his body
Janet reveals that they had been
entering the wrong coordinates all this
time and that's why they couldn't even
find a Trey of her she is positive that
they will meet again but she also warns
them that they only have two hours to
make things work after that the quantum
realm will become so unstable that they
won't be able to reach her for the next
100 years elsewhere the black market
dealer Birch and his goons swarm Lewis's
office and ask him where Scott is as
expected Lewis refuses to betray his
friend but he eventually speaks up when
Burch injects him with a truth serum
just then Ava appears out of nowhere
threatens the goons to stay away from
Scott and fleas it turns out she was
secretly overhearing their conversation
and now she also knows where the secret
lab is based meanwhile Birch calls the
FBI and informs them that Scott is
currently out violating his house arrest
fortunately right after they leave Lewis
calls his best buddy and warns him to
return home as soon as possible Scott
using his special suit pulls a Bueller
and manages to do that in the nick of
time in the forest hope and Hank shrink
their lab and are about to leave when
suddenly the FBI surrounds them m one of
the cops tries taking the lab away but
Ava arrives there knocks him out and
takes the lab for herself when Scott
gets wind of this he immediately breaks
the father-daughter Duo out of the FBI
headquarters using his trained ants
Lewis also arrives there and decides to
join them following this they track the
lab to a building where Bill has already
started his experiments however he
doesn't make much progress as the giant
ants quickly surround him then Hank uses
his old suit and goes inside the quantum
realm to find Janet after the lab is
shrunken again Ava suddenly arrives and
starts attacking Scott who is now
transformed into Ant-Man in the meantime
Lewis and hope Escape in a vehicle after
a while Scott Trix Ava and joins his
friends in the car but they are soon
chased by Birch and his men in the midst
of all the chaos Scott turns into giant
man hope turns into the wasp and Ava
once again arrives as they are fighting
all over the city Birch takes the lab
and flees to the docks where he boards a
ship to get away Scott follows him and
this time he turns into the largest
version of giant man he easily retrieves
the lab but when he is about to return
to the shore he has difficulty breathing
due to his large size soon he falls
unconscious and drowns inside the water
but luckily hope rescues him on the
other hand Hank navigates through the
quantum realm using the coordinates
Janet gave him until he finally locates
her after all these years of research
and hard work he has succeeded and the
couple reunites with an emotional kiss
she's not even mad that he gave her up
for dad for his entire life meanwhile
the lab returns to its original size in
the middle of the city Ava and Bill
arrive there and start extracting
Janet's Quantum energy in hopes of
saving Ava this causes Janet who is
inside the realm to suddenly lose energy
but luckily before things get out of
hand Scott and hope arrive and disable
the machine giving Hank and Janet enough
time to get out of the quantum realm
When Hope sees her mom for the first
time in over two decades she cannot
contain her tears and immediately goes
to embrace her after the emotional Union
Janet notices Ava's condition so she
approaches her and touches her face
surprisingly the girl stops phasing
after staying in the quantum realm for
so long Janet has gained powers to do so
but Ava still needs a lot of energy to
be fully fixed as the group heads out
Burch and his goons are waiting for them
but this time Lewis incapacitates them
with the help of his friends soon the
police arrive at the scene and to rest
the bad guys meanwhile after the videos
of Ant-Man emerge on the news detective
Wu believes that Scott has violated his
house arrest he quickly goes to check
but to his surprise Scott is there
impressed by his sincerity Wu declares
that his house arrest is finally over in
the final scene the movie appears to end
on a happy note Hank and Janet start
living happily near a beach Lewis finds
a wealthy client and hope and Scott
start a relationship in the post-credits
scene however things go south the
scientist couple and hope set up the
quantum tunnel and have Scott enter it
to bring back some Quantum energy for
Ava however when he is about to return
big dick big daddy Thanos snaps his
fingers and wipes out half of the
Earth's population unfortunately for
Scott Hank Janet and hope are all gone
he is left clueless about what happened
as the radio suddenly goes silent Scott
is now trapped in the quantum realm with
no way of escaping it the movie ends as
we are shown a small Montage of the
deserted city of San Francisco half of
the population has vanished but inside
Scott's Home the large ant is still
alive and enjoying himself on the drum
set
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching